for Joellen bead James Harden and the
Philadelphia 76ers
ready standing by with Jason Tatum
thank you so much Spiro there was a ton
of back and forth lead changes ties
throughout this game what was the
turning point for you all I think in
that fourth quarter four minutes left we
uh we made winning plays and we talked
about it before the game do whatever it
takes
and essentially don't ask I don't ask
the guys anything to do anything I
wouldn't do pick up full court block
shots dive on the floor start from the
top and rest will follow uh we made when
it plays extra kick out Al made big
shots smart made big shots JB uh this is
a tough one it feels good that we won
speaking of tough the last time that the
Hawks had that sideline out of bounds
play it took them four attempts to get
it in the fourth attempt resulted in a
turnover tell us about that defensive
effort uh we were just we was locked in
that felt like the longest possession
ever uh but you know we was all on the
same page communicating you know
switching to the point of contact uh and
you know it worked out all right so now
you're officially moving on you're
facing the Philadelphia 76ers what are
you looking forward to out of that
series uh it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be exciting uh I want to enjoy this one
right now I want to send an apology to
uh the legend Janet Jackson were you
supposed to close it out in Boston she
had to postpartners show I hope she see
this uh you know I apologize for that
but we got it done today very gracious
of you congratulations thank you guys
take it back gracious indeed what a
night great stuff Stephanie what